this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the alabama platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more about them in just a bit
he was one of the greatest presidents in
us history elected in 1912 on a platform
of protecting the little man woodrow
wilson hit washington like a progressive
missile under his watch monopolies were
smashed up protections brought in for
workers the basis of the modern banking
system created as a wartime leader too
he was unimpeachable bringing moral
conviction to the endgame of one of
history's bloodiest conflicts at least
that's one way we could open this video
an introduction that might be subtitled
the progressive hero but there's another
darker version an opening we might call
the authoritarian in this version we'd
start by intoning that wilson was
perhaps one of the worst presidents in
american history from there we'd list
his crimes his staggering racism is
crushing of civil liberties his
invasions of mexico haiti the dominican
republic in this opening wilson wouldn't
be a hero but a man who used a tiny
mandate to trample the constitution so
which is it which one of today's two
openings is real as we're about to find
out in this video is both
[Music]
thomas woodrow wilson was born december
28 1856 into a family of what were then
known as doe faces this is mid 19th
century speak for northerners who
sympathized with southerners and it
summed up his parents perfectly the
boy's father reverend joseph
ruggles-wilson was an ohio lad who'd
quit the buckeye state moved south and
became more fiercely southern than
jefferson davis when the civil war broke
out reverend wilson would join the
confederate army as a chaplain nor was
much different an english woman who'd
moved across the pond jesse woodrow
wilson would spend the war tending
wounded southern soldiers one of
wilson's earliest memories was watching
his beloved mama look after the injured
in their quaint little georgian town
perhaps unsurprisingly it would be
moments like this that came to define
the boy's early life in 1864
seven-year-old wilson witnessed
sherman's march to the seas the union
general swept through georgia leaving
ruin in his wake just months later he
watched as confederate commander robert
e lee slowly made his way into augusta
weary
and defeated in later life wilson would
say that he never forgot looking up into
the general's eyes but of course hard
memories didn't end with the south's
defeat the family lived through
reconstruction a time wilson remembered
not as an attempt to integrate a
racially divided society but one of
clawing fear in the newly freed slaves
the family saw only criminals recalling
this era wilson would write the task of
ordinary labor stood untouched the
idlers grew insolent dangerous knights
went anxiously by for fear of riot and
incendiary fire although the family
moved to a racially mixed town in 1870
wilson would never forget these moments
justice he'd never forget the lessons
taught to him by ex-confederate soldiers
in the makeshift schools son ran for
cash lessons filled with the romance of
the lost cause still there were other
influences in his life beyond those of
the war shattered south his father
impressed upon wilson a firm
presbyterian faith one which would
ensure the boy always believed he was
doing god's work there was his love of
reading too particularly on british
history which would help form his
political beliefs but perhaps the
greatest influence was ellen louise axon
the daughter of a southern clergyman
ellen was both an artist and a woman
dedicated to social causes it's from her
that wilson would discover his
progressive instincts his desire to
stand up for the ordinary man well so
long as that ordinary man was white but
we'll come to that later for now let's
just sit back and watch as wilson
graduates with his phd thanks to a
thesis that argued for replacing the
american system with a strong
centralized executive like in britain
let's watch too as he grows into a
devoutly religious man capable of great
warmth to his friends and cold cruelty
to anyone he thought had slighted him
it's this man who in 1902 would be
offered the job of president of
princeton university one of america's
top ivy league schools princeton at this
time was in desperate need of reform a
place stuck firmly in a fusty
comfortable past wilson was determined
to change that treating his role more
like a dictator of princeton rather than
a president the southern gentleman set
about shaking things up with all the
delicacy of a category 5 hurricane
blowing away the old order and building
a modern system atop the ruins it was
wilson in a nutshell disruption in the
name of a greater progressive goal one
that soon got him noticed by new
jersey's politicians but even here there
was a dark side to his approach as
president of princeton wilson was
instrumental in stopping black students
from enrolling in an era when racism was
saturating american society this went
mostly unnoticed it would only be in
hindsight that people realized what an
insight it afforded into wilson's true
character
[Music]
in 1910 new jersey democrats had a
problem previous years had seen their
party beset by scandals and the
corrosive influence of machine politics
a system let's scratch my back and i'll
scratch yours and or scratch my back and
i'll give you the contents of the
straight treasury if they wanted to win
the upcoming race for governor they'd
have to find a new kind of candidate one
untainted by all of this graft someone
like say the president of a popular
university on hearing their offer
wilson's one demand was that he'd be
able to govern with no strings attached
thinking this naive academic would be
easy to control the party bosses were
all like nothing only to watch in horror
as wilson exploded everything in both
the race and his governorship new jersey
got a crash course in all the best and
all the worst aspects of woodrow wilson
styling himself as an unconstitutional
governor wilson attacked democrat
machine politics with a cudgel bringing
in anti-corruption measures designed to
loosen boss's grip on the party he
unveiled a slew of progressive reforms
including workers compensation laws at
the same time this was only made
possible by a disregard for convention
and a drive to centralize power in his
own hands but for a man who literally
believed that he was doing god's work
what did such niceties matter by 1912
wilson's star was rising in the larger
democratic party a party desperately in
need of fresh blood the last time a
democrat of what a presidential election
had been when grover cleveland nabbed a
second non-consecutive term in 1892 and
even then had been an anomaly the only
democrat elected since the civil war in
other words the party was ready for a
change of direction and who was to say
that new direction couldn't be embodied
by a perspective academic with the look
of a disappointed priest after a
bruising battle at that summer's
convention wilson took the nomination
with a platform that included everything
from smashing monopolies and introducing
a federal income tax to securing
independence for the philippines yet his
candidacy was considered a long shot bid
the republicans under william howard
taft were sitting comfortably in the
white house it would take something
extraordinary to dislodge them
the ultimate black swan event in the end
though it wouldn't be a black swan that
saved wilson
but a bull moose taft's predecessor had
been teddy roosevelt a vigorous
chest-thumping man who cared little
about keeping his opinions to himself
and his opinion in 1912 was that taft
was a corpulent waste of space blocking
the country from what it needed a third
term of rooseveltian testosterone at the
convention taft's allies panickedly
blocked roosevelt's delegates lest he
nab the nomination so roosevelt founded
his own progressive party popularly
known as the bull moose party and began
an electrifying independent bid for the
presidency the result was a campaign
that saw president have dropped from
front runner to third place has been as
wilson and teddy slugged it out
privately wilson didn't rate his chances
admitting that he felt like a colorless
school master next to the former
president but since this is a video on
woodrow wilson 28th president not
woodrow wilson random guy who lost to
teddy roosevelt you can probably guess
what happened next on november 5th the
republican vote was split hopelessly
between roosevelt and taft although he
squeaked a mere 41.8 percent of the
popular vote less than the losing
candidate in most elections the result
was an electoral college landslide for
wilson on march the 4th 1913 the
southern gentleman was sworn in the last
president to arrive at his inauguration
in a horse-drawn carriage it was the
beginning of the wilsonian era eight
years that would be a great success for
some
and another disaster for others now just
before we continue with today's video a
quick word from today's wonderful
sponsor squarespace look it's the age of
creation think about it everyone is out
there on the internet making something
we're no longer just reading blogs or
listening to podcasts or watching
youtube we're increasingly making these
things so you've probably either got a
great idea yourself or you know someone
who does and when it's time to move that
project from your head to the screen in
front of you that's where squarespace
comes in is the perfect web tool to help
you fashion the internet into whatever
you want it to be maybe the hands-on
type lots of opinions and ideas about
exactly what your site should look like
great squarespace got all the
customization tools you could ever want
with no technical bs to worry about or
maybe you just need something functional
something that works with minimal
thoughts so you could focus on your
content rather than just the coat of
paint if so good news squarespace has
tons of beautiful templates that you can
use and once you're done setting up your
website there are many extra features on
squarespace so your site can thrive
email campaigns patronage portals social
integrations member only areas analytics
commercial options 24 customer support
everything you could ever want is in one
place so when you're ready to get
started on the next big project of yours
big or small it involves a website you
gotta do it with squarespace go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new
site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll save 10 of your
first purchase of a website or domain
and now back to it
[Music]
from the moment he took office wilson
had a clear vision of what the
presidency should be less ceremonial
role and more like some sort of old
timey king a month after his
inauguration he demonstrated his active
approach by becoming the first president
since john adams to address congress and
so the starting gun was fired on a slew
of reforms in this first term we can
helpfully divide most of these reforms
into four categories work money business
race in the work category you have stuff
like wilson's support for an eight-hour
workday or his attempts to tackle the
thorny issue of child labour really
though it was in the other categories he
made the biggest impact especially
regarding money it was wilson's
administration that established the
federal reserve still the system that
underpins banking in the united states
today it was also wilson who pushed for
congress to establish a permanent
federal income tax recently made
possible by the passage of the 16th
amendment now this wasn't completely new
congress had previously levied an income
tax back in the civil war but wilson's
first term marked the beginning of
federal income tax as a fact of life one
that continues to this day there would
also be similar upheavals for business
one of wilson's big deals was his
intense loathing of monopolies and a
desire to break them up to that ant he
pursued first tariff reform then
anti-trust legislation then finally
established the federal trade commission
to investigate and punish
anti-competitive business practices but
while how you feel about these reforms
probably depends on your general
feelings towards things like taxes and
sending children up chimney flus things
aren't so subjective regarding our final
category on race wilson's record was
woeful as a man of the south who'd lived
through reconstruction wilson had some
pretty fixed ideas on race relations the
main idea being that there shouldn't be
relations between the races
at all despite this he actively courted
the black vote in 1912 and hopes were
high that his progressive reforms would
include non-white people once in office
though wilson simply couldn't shake his
inner good old boy a month after his
inauguration wilson signed off on a plan
to re-segregate the mail service up till
this point the federal government had
been one of the few places that black
folk could easily get hired and even
ascend to well-paid managerial positions
this was something previous presidents
had fiercely guarded both taft and
roosevelt had championed an integrated
workforce then wilson entered office and
everything changed in 1913 the post
office and treasury both introduced
segregation with separate workspaces
bathrooms and cafeterias within no time
at all the practice was spreading across
federal departments but it didn't stop
with the bathrooms swathes of black
workers were demoted had their pay
slashed or were just straight up fired
wilson himself sacked 15 of the federal
services 17 black supervisors replacing
them all with white dudes for
middle-class black people hit by these
reforms it wasn't just damaging it was
humiliating here were people who'd spent
their entire lives working for the
government pulling their families up
towards prosperity only to have it all
snatched away
with no explanation it's not like wilson
was blind to these effects in 1914 black
leaders came to him in the white house
and begged him to reverse course to
their shock wasn't told them segregation
is not humiliating but a benefit and
ought to be so regarded by you gentlemen
by then that was woodrow wilson all over
even by the abysmal standards of his
time he was simply a racist unable to
conceive that black people might be
deserving of equal treatment or that the
antebellum south might not have been
that great for enslaved people you can
see this from one of his notable firsts
the first movie to be screened at the
white house it was birth the nation a
hateful if technically impressive screed
in which the ku klux klan are portrayed
as the good guys by most accounts wilson
thoroughly enjoyed it
[Music]
for all domestic issues that may have
absorbed most of wilson's attention it
was a crisis brewing thousands miles
away that would determine his historical
reputation olsen had been on the job for
17 months when world war erupted turning
europe's meadows into some of the worst
killing fields imaginable but when teddy
roosevelt would advocate an american
role in the great war wilson wanted no
such thing with one in seven americans
born in the country now super killing
one another the 28th president was
acutely aware of the discord u.s
involvement could cause so he became a
fierce champion of neutrality although
admittedly a type of neutrality that
still ignored the german naval blockade
of the british isles this last point led
to a catastrophe in 1915 when a u-boat
sank the british ship lusitania off the
coast of ireland 1200 people died
including 128 americans the outrage
nearly pulled the us into the war it was
only after germany agreed to pull back
its submarine warfare that wilson was
able to step back from the brink
he probably felt relieved after all by
this time his administration was already
involved in a kaleidoscope of foreign
military adventures despite personally
advocating a more peaceful approach to
latin america wilson sure as heck was
not shy about sending troops south of
the border in april 1914 the arrest of
some american sailors in revolutionary
mexico led wilson to order the marines
to occupy veracruz an action that lasted
till november remarkably this was pretty
short by wilson's standards 1915 saw
wilson respond to political chaos in
haiti by having the entire country
occupied kicking off an
afghanistan-style attempt at a nation
building that would last until 1934. the
following year 1916 uncle sam vaulted
over haiti's border and likewise
occupied the dominican republic in both
cases the stated aim was to end chaos
and turn the two nations into functional
democracies in both cases
america would fail miserably still not
every adventure abroad ended in disaster
in 1917 wilson helped usher through
congress a bill that began paving the
way for filipino independence handing
the philippines a degree of autonomy in
a similar vein he also signed the bill
making puerto rico a territory and
granting its inhabitants u.s citizenship
as well as one that purchased the virgin
islands from denmark we'd be lying
though if we didn't admit that most of
wilson's foreign policy tended to focus
on sending men with guns to various
places in one case in 1916 this almost
led to war with mexico after u.s forces
were sent across the border without
permission to try and capture pancho
villa as payback for a raid on an
american town still as wilson prepared
his re-election campaign he could
reasonably claim to have kept the us out
of any major wars it was this record
that he ran on under the slogan he kept
us out of war and it likely led to his
second term when all the votes were
counted in 1916 wilson had carried
california the state that allowed him to
squeak a narrow electoral college
victory by a mere
0.38 percent it is thought californian
irish and german communities had put him
over the top as a reward for staying out
of world war one but if that was the
case then oh boy were voters in for some
disappointment by the time wilson gave
his second inaugural address in march
1917 america would be hurtling headlong
into war
[Music]
to be fair to wilson options for staying
out of world war one in spring 1917 were
pretty meager that february germany had
resumed unrestricted submarine warfare
vaulting over an american red line worse
till british intelligence had
intercepted and published the zimmermann
telegram a german message to mexico that
basically went what else do you ask
fancy invading the united states we
promise to let you keep texas with such
flagrant provocations wilson did the
only thing he realistically could on
april 2 1917 he asked congress to
declare war on germany and he got his
wish and so began the most controversial
part of wilson's presidency the
declaration of war unleashed wilson's
centralizing power hoarding tendencies
to an
unbelievable degree overnight swaths of
american industry were nationalized
including the railroad and telephone
networks and in practice if not name the
shipping industry special agencies began
to sprout up like mushrooms dedicated to
redirecting all aspects of public life
towards winning the war there were
agencies to work with business with
unions to flood the nation with pro-war
propaganda to increase food production
such changes had enormous impact on
american life from little things like
the introduction of daylight savings
time to the ascent of herbert hoover who
first became prominent in politics
spearheading a food-saving drive but
many though the most immediate impact
came in two forms in their finances and
in the draft as america shifted to a war
economy wilson brought in new income
taxes to finance it but while that stung
some pocketbooks others got fatter than
they'd ever been all this increased
production pushed employment up to
nearly a hundred percent among those
newly employed were the 2.8 million
conscripted into the army the first
american draft since the civil war this
included 400 000 african-americans yet
even now the administration couldn't
shake its reflexive racism throughout
world war one army units would be
segregated while black men in the navy
would be stuck doing food service not
that it was only black people america
was now discriminating against the
advent of war unleashed a wave of ugly
nationalism wilson did little to hold
back in the streets german americans
were in danger of intimidation and
physical assault one man robert prager
was even lynched others suffered baldur
but no less painful discriminations from
being fired from their jobs to
xenophobic rulings in some states that
banned these foreign languages perhaps
the most notorious change though was the
suspension of civil liberties the
espionage and sedition acts were so
sweeping they effectively made criticism
of the government or armed forces
illegal in total 1 500 americans would
be successfully prosecuted by the wilson
administration under these acts
including socialist leader eugene debs
sentenced to 10
years for opposing the draft nor was it
only public speech that was targeted
wilson empowered the post office to read
and censor people's mail newspapers were
subject to censorship for speaking out
against the war all in all then the era
was likely the most tightly controlled
period in american life between the
civil war and world war ii for many even
today this remains wilson's unforgivable
sin but while the home front was marred
in controversy it was a different story
abroad the first u.s troops reached
europe in june 1917. by october the
american expeditionary force was
augmenting french and british units in
early 1918 they were independently
scoring victories that fall they'd play
a key role in the musargon offensive in
all some 116 000 americans would die in
european trenches but they'd succeed in
what they came to do faced with this
influx of manpower on the allied side
the central powers will to fight
collapsed come november 11th 1918 world
war one was over now all that was left
to do was figure out the piece
if you visit central europe today it
won't be long before you find somewhere
named after woodrow wilson here in
prague for instance wilson over eliza
runs by the main station over impulse
end there's a bridge to the east in
bruno a forest and that's just the czech
republic the patent repeats across
countries in this region a topographical
reminder of how a generation of
europeans viewed the 28th president much
of this is thanks to the 14 points an
address wilson made in january 1918
calling for among other things the
breakup of the austro-hungarian empire
and the creation of poland that was
followed 11 months later with a trip to
europe the first of any sitting u.s
president there vast crowds gathered to
cheer tens of thousands grateful for u.s
food shipments for america recognizing
their new nations if your view of wilson
is primarily as a man who trampled civil
liberties the idea of him as a hero
might seem strange yet to europeans
that's exactly what he was and it's one
reason why there's no comparable
movement over here to take his name off
buildings even if he was a bit of a
racist tool still all this goodwill
doesn't mean wilson succeeded in his
european objectives when he arrived in
france the president's goals included
peace without victory or not making
germany suffer and establishing a league
of nations to prevent future wars on
that first point wilson would fail
miserably the eye-watering reparations
forced on berlin by the allies were so
humiliating that they arguably led to
world war ii the second point though
seemed to be heading for success the
countries at the peace conference agreed
to wilson's cherished league of nations
in 1920 it became a geopolitical reality
but america would never be among its
members by 1919 republicans were firmly
in control of congress and only a
handful were willing to vote with wilson
rather than negotiate wilson instead
tried going directly to the public
embarking on a major speaking tour to
convince america of the rightness of his
plans it was an exhausting project one
that saw wilson cover some ten thousand
miles sadly his body couldn't take such
a demanding schedule on october the
second days after collapsing wilson
suffered a horrific stroke half
paralyzed the president went into
seclusion sending orders through his
second wife edith in fact this seclusion
was so total that many suspect edith
wilson secretly ran the government
acting as stand-in president for the
incapacitated wilson all of which may
explain the fate of the league told
republicans would only vote for a
compromise version requiring
congressional assent to send soldiers on
league business wilson decided to kill
the bill entirely it was the end of
american involvement in the league and
frankly the end of wilson's time as a
mover of history sure his last years
would see some significant events the
advent of women's suffrage the racial
violence of red summer really though
wilson's biography more or less ends
here with his body broken and his dreams
of a new international order reduced to
so much dust woodrow wilson left office
on march 4th 1921 following a landslide
win by affably corrupt republican warren
g harding moving into a washington home
he spent his retirement as a virtual
hermit dreaming of a third presidential
run that everyone knew could never
happen wilson died after a second stroke
on february 3 1924 at the age of 67. at
the end of his life he was sure his
legacy was secure that his time in
office had been spent as god himself had
wished yet with a century of hindsight
we can see this wasn't true in scholarly
rankings wilson has gone from a top five
president to one who was recently ranked
at 13. with more attention being paid to
his racism it seems that his star is
only going to sink lower indeed it's not
uncommon to find people today who will
assert that he was the worst president
ever while that order probably goes to
james buchanan from a civil liberties
point of view it's hard to dispute that
wilson was uniquely terrible and yet
there's more to this story than just
wilson the villain to a whole generation
of europeans wilson was undoubtedly a
hero a man who saved the continent in
its hour of need for american workers
too he helped improve conditions for
millions passing on real tangible
benefits if we could split these two
sides of wilson into separate videos
it'd be so much easier one titled the
great president and one called the
disaster but of course they weren't
separate they were one person one
president who did so much good while
simultaneously doing so much evil
whether that makes him a success a
notable failure or a dark warning
is up to each of us to decide
hope you found today's video interesting
if you did please do hit that like
button below don't forget to subscribe
and thank you for watching
[Music]